The Joe Rogan Experience what if that's
a real guy in there like a skeleton did
you know there was a they found uh there
was a Buddha statue once and they found
out that it was actually a mummified
Buddha that they had covered with a
statue they did an x-ray on this thing
and inside of it is like an actual
Buddha guy like an actual Yogi who was
in a Lotus position that they did the
Statue around him well that's not that
weird well it's weird that they didn't
know it people had the statue they
didn't know it was a dead guy how old
was the statue that's a good question
because if it was you know I mean
there's tombs and mummies and everything
all over the place but look at the
Statue I think that's unreal that's what
I want that's crazy right
see like that thing he ain't clicking
that thing a little thing in the corner
he has to sign up to the History Channel
because he's like yeah
every time go could you pull back up to
the images again like so is a uh a monk
a mummified monk inside an ancient
Buddhist statue which is wild man
because I don't know what the statue is
made of but it looks like it's a little
bit like Pottery what does that look
like
medical examination of a
thousand-year-old Buddha statue revealed
a shocking surprise hidden inside an
actual person's body
so
um Meander Medical Center in the Dutch
town of amsterfoot
of course amsterfort has plenty of
experience treating senior citizens but
none as old as the 1 000 year old
patient who came
research has brought a millennium old
statue of Buddha of the Buddha which had
been on loan from the drence museum in
the Netherlands to the state of the art
Hospital in the hopes that the modern
Medical Technology should could shed
light on an ancient mystery for hidden
inside the gold painted figure was uh
was a secret The Mummy of a Buddhist
monk in a Lotus position shown outside
of China for the first time last year so
how do they know though that's what's
confusing did they open it up did they
ruin the whole thing and open it up I
don't think they did man just leave it
in well they sampled the material for
DNA it said
hegelman slid an ancient artifacts
slowly into a high-tech Imaging machine
for a full body CT scan and sampled bone
material real for DNA testing
gastroenterologist
say that word gastro gastroenterologist
and say say his name now
try that uh roin out Vermin flannel
[Laughter]
the vermish did verbiage did used a
specialty a specially designed endoscope
to extract samples from the mummy's
chest and abdominal cavities now it's
known the test have revealed a surprise
the Monk's organs had been removed and
replaced with scraps of paper printed
with ancient Chinese characters and
other rotted materials since has not
been identified how the organs had been
taken from the mummy remains of mystery
wow that's cool I wonder why they knew
there was something in there though like
that's not normal that you threw a
[ __ ] yeah you go into a CT scan
so look scroll up there no you're right
there the body inside the Statue is
thought to be that of the Buddhist
Master Liu Kwon a member of the Chinese
meditation school who died around A.D
1100 how did luquan's body end up inside
I hope I'm saying that right end up
inside ancient Chinese statue one
possibility explored by the drenth
museum is is the gruesome process of
self-mummification in which monks hope
to transform themselves into revered
living Buddhas oh whoa he put himself in
there the practice of self-mummification
amongst Buddhist monks was most common
in Japan but occurred elsewhere in Asia
including China as described in Ken
Jeremiah's book living Buddhas monks
interested in self-mummification spent
upwards of a decade following a special
diet that gradually starved their bodies
and enhanced their chances of
preservation holy [ __ ] they issued any
food I never know how to say that word
because they'll only read it how do you
say that word eschewed issued that's a
word that I've never said issued I'm 54.
I've never seen that word I've seen that
word but I've only read it I've never
actually said it out loud any food made
from rice wheat and soybeans and instead
ate nuts berries tree bark and pine
needles and slowly diminishing
quantities to reduce body fat and
moisture which can cause corpse to Decay
whoa they also ate herbs
what is that word sisad kaisad scissad
nuts and sesame seeds to inhibit
bacterial growth holy [ __ ] they drank a
poisonous tree sap that was used to make
lacquer
so that the toxicity would repel insects
and pervade the body as an embalming
fluid pervade wow [ __ ] they went on a
10-year diet to kill themselves what the
[ __ ] and turn themselves in but you know
that was a thing with the Buddha like
there's images of the Buddha like the
original Buddha that was like he was
starved to death have you ever seen
those no they made statues of the Buddha
where he was like basically a skeleton
they're they're weird statues and that
was a I guess a part of that process see
if you can find any of those
um skeleton-like Buddha statues how
would you say it starved Buddha statues
but that was like a thing that they
would they would make these images of
the Buddha in this state where he was
apparently probably going through that
thing like yeah those oh oh [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] that's like some man of Indiana
Jones that's scary see go to that quora
um thing what is the emaciated body of
the Buddhist State statue represent
uh they're not really good not good
answers sometimes by anybody though but
let's see it represents the six-year
period of renunciation that the Buddha
practiced from age 20 to 36
approximately 446 to 440 BC
based on traditional Indian especially
uh saramana belief in self-mortification
before he realized the futility of
extreme asceticism
and renounced it as when as well when he
was on the verge of dying so he wised up
so the Buddha did the same thing those
monks did and he was like what the [ __ ]
am I doing he stopped he stopped what
the [ __ ] am I doing I'm pronounced this
but look he had gotten to the point of
basically almost death
so that practice since okay so that's
446 BC so this that statue was older
than that
so the statue is a thousand years old
right it was a thousand BC wasn't it no
no no it was a thousand years a thousand
so it was a thousand A.D right yeah so
this was pre that so that guy was
probably he didn't get the full wire
that the Buddha bailed on he didn't get
the facts yeah he didn't get the full
details so he decided Well the Buddha
was a [ __ ] yeah and he quit and to do
what the Buddha couldn't do I'm not a
[ __ ] quitter I want to be a statue
[ __ ] I'm gonna be better than the
Buddha but that's the whole Buddhist
monk thing is an odd practice anyway
right because I'm a dumbass can you just
explain is there's more than one Buddha
right or has been or well there's the
Buddha and there's like thought to be
the look at that image of them whoa look
at his guts all right so I was wondering
what it feels like holding something or
what that is I think that just
representing his hands man that's his
hips buddy oh that's that's no stomach
at all this is organs had shrunk up yeah
I think he's got too many ribs though
this [ __ ] need to take an anatomy
lesson
does he have too many ribs how many ribs
do you have do you even know how many
ribs some of it's a muscle 26. I made
that up completely so I'm just because
there's muscle up there but they look
different than the other one to the left
that one looks more realistic like that
one there the the tan looking yeah that
looks more realistic see that looks like
real ribs look at these sunken eyes so
look at the ribs on that one and look at
the ribs on that gray one right there
that gray one looks fake as [ __ ] it's
too many ribs how many ribs do you think
you have I don't know how many ribs you
have I'm going 26 26 you mean both sides
no all up 26. I might be thinking of
teeth
I might be confused I don't know how
many teeth you have either but if you
say think of how many ribs you have on
each side let me guess let me without
touching my own ribs one two three four
one I might have gone a bit too soon I'm
gonna stick with it I'm gonna say 22.
I'm gonna say
I'm gonna say 11 on each side
12 on each side is it 12 oh 12 pairs 24.
you're pretty close we're right in the
middle you said 22. yeah so but what
look at his though look at that one that
one weird one that we just saw that
[ __ ] guy had like 50. how many has he
got he's got [ __ ] tons which I like
about that look at that nice muscle he's
got going on you like that look at that
look at that nice muscle he's got going
on there bro that's skin yeah that guy
that is that's tendon that probably that
guy can't curl a [ __ ] peptide Jack of
white out like I didn't lift no you lift
bro you lift bro how many has he got
there he's got too many let's count them
he looks like Predator he's got too many
they put nipples on him though too it's
like the Batman suit how many has he got
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen sixteen Seventeen yeah he's got
too many ribs they didn't know what the
[ __ ] they were doing it's all fake
fake news fake news this is [ __ ]
fake news bro but that's a that whole
Buddhist monk thing the suffering thing
is a strange thing I have I had a friend
who became a monk yeah yeah I became a
monk while I knew him he was a friend of
mine from Taekwondo
his name is Joe and uh we used to train
together and he just decided at one
point in time that he wanted to uh go to
this uh Buddhism this Buddhist temple to
learn Buddhism and to to he wanted to
get control over his mind because he got
very nervous during sparring and got
very nervous
um when he when it came time for
training and and competing he competed a
few times too he would just like lose
his [ __ ] and he was he's like maybe
meditation would help me get through
this so he started meditating and taking
these uh like Buddhist practices and
doing this time at the temple and then
uh switched to a strict vegetarian diet
and then completely quit doing Taekwondo
and just became a monk and we used to go
visit him and uh we used to go visit Joe
the monk where did he live at a
monastery yeah he lived in a monastery
he swept up at a temple
it was very odd because I knew him
before that and you know he was a guy
that we would train with yeah right and
then over time he became a monk and you
know he silent no no he would talk and
he would laugh and joke around with you
and stuff but like you would only eat
vegetables and he would uh he would
never speak badly about anyone or
anything it was really interesting did
he see him happy
is a weird thing like what has happened
like he didn't he's in content he didn't
have a mate he didn't have a wife or a
boyfriend or he didn't you know he
didn't have there was no one in his life
that you know he it seemed like it was
just him and meditation and silence and
he would like uh he had a co-on you know
like there's a thing you're supposed to
meditate on I think that's what a koan
is and like his was the sound of like it
was like one of those the sound of one
hand clapping thing oh yeah right I
don't think that was it but it was that
kind of thing where he's falling in the
woods runs around well it's you're
supposed to think about it like
constantly even though it doesn't
necessarily make sense and the idea is
like that through that you somehow or
another achieve enlightenment by
focusing on this one thing over and over
and over and over again I mean when
maybe that's like some sort of a brain
hack
but I remember I was a kid at the time
when he did this I was uh probably 16
something like that it was 15 when I
knew him and then maybe like 16 17 when
he when he became a monk and we would go
visit him it was very it was very
strange we go to eat with him we'd have
to eat vegetables
would he come out and go into the
wherever you were yeah he was like a
good place to go and go and have some
drinks this was in Boston he would no he
wouldn't have drinks no way he just
drank water and tea
um and he was uh he was different man
like he he was all in like he had
decided that that was his life and you
know he was subscribing to all of their
belief systems and their practices and
did you and your friends ever at any
stage think we got to get him out of
there like maybe he's being brainwashed
or something or no I mean he was older
than us you know it's like we we weren't
in a position to tell him what to do
right because we were all all of us were
like uh around the same age maybe they I
was the youngest guy but only by like a
year or two and I think Joe was like
30ish so we were like teens early 20s
and this guy was in his 30s and he was
hanging around a bunch of teenagers well
he was training with us okay I wasn't
hanging out
we were all training at the same uh
Taekwondo school and you know he
just decided that that was his life and
he seemed content I'll say that it
didn't seem like happy is like you're
around someone they got a big smile on
their face they love what they do like
happy as you catch a big fish yeah right
well yeah yeah he wasn't that but he
seemed like he was on this path and this
path provided him some sort of clarity
or some peace in his life that he seemed
was worth
sacrificing all like he didn't have sex
he was done and we were joking around
with him about that like like that's it
forever no more sex did he jack off no
no masturbation holy [ __ ] I know that's
what I say maybe he [ __ ] a pillow
maybe you know maybe he's in a trance
you know how monks [ __ ] pillows you know
yeah pretended I don't know what he did
you know but he uh he was the first guy
that I ever met that sort of like left
society and he I remember he stayed at
this Temple that we we knew where the
temple was we'd go see him there I have
nine people that have done that kind of
left Society but not that deep like
they've gone to a remote island in
Indonesia and they just Surf and yeah
you know I've heard of that before yeah
I know people that have sort of like
dropped out and you know live in a small
town live in a log cabin and [ __ ] and
I've thought about it I think it'd be
good
I'd get too frustrated I think there's
something to that there's something to
like being in the woods and there's
something to just being alone with
nature